russia is putting the u.s on notice this
morning as the biden administration
sends more weapons to ukraine russian
president vladimir putin warned the
white house to stop arming ukraine and
said there would be quote unpredictable
consequences the warning comes as moscow
escalates its offensive in eastern
ukraine and tries to recover from recent
major defeats including the sinking of
one of its warships deborah alfarone is
at the white house with the very latest
deborah good morning
good morning michelle the white house
says that 800 million dollars worth of
weapons are expected to arrive in
ukraine soon this as the administration
is considering which high level ranking
official they're going to send to
ukraine as an additional show of support
the latest shipment of weapons by the
biden administration brings the total to
more than two and a half billion dollars
since the russian invasion began 52 days
ago
for the first time weapons will include
heavy artillery in addition to more
javelin anti-tank missiles
we're continuing to supply ukraine with
the weapons resources they need to
defend their country we won't be able to
advertise every piece of security we
give because our allies and partners are
supplying to ukraine through us
but advanced weapons and ammunition are
flowing in every single day
russia is drawing a line sending a
formal diplomatic note to the biden
administration warning the u.s against
further arming ukraine
as the conflict intensifies in eastern
ukraine president vladimir zelinsky has
been hosting a number of allied leaders
in the capital kiev including a surprise
visit by uk's prime minister boris
johnson last weekend
before he boarded air force one thursday
president biden was asked if he would go
you sent senior officials to ukraine
we're making that decision now
thank you who would you send what was
the reason you're ready to go
white house press secretary jen saki
said the president would not make that
trip he is ready he's ready for anything
the man likes a fast car some aviators
he's ready to go to ukraine
it's true he does
we are not sending the president to
ukraine
both the president and vice president
have visited neighboring countries since
russia invaded ukraine but the logistics
just the security involved with sending
someone so high level it's incredibly
enormous dana all right deborah thank
you very much